GOOD MORNING JOHN, IT'S FRIDAY!!!
Hey, found a dungeon.
So this is backstage.
So this first room is just gross and wet
But then this room
Tinker fantasy.
Oh, Oh
It's keeps going
It smells a lot like motor oil
and there's a canoe!
'Cause, you know
and then up here,
there's a hole *sounds concerned*
Don't wor-don't worry about it
Feel like it's necessary for me to take this opportunity to hang out in this spot
and talk a little bit.
Going on tour is a strange thing.
You see it from the front for a long time
And there's something like, undeniably cool about it
About poeple who are up on the stage
like, they're PHYSICALLY lifted off the ground
It's less glamorous in person, but it's still cool
I mean... this is amazing
I'm pretty sure I shouldn't be down here, but it's amazing!
There are hard work elements, there are boring elements but it is an honor and a privilege
To be able to do this with people
I feel like I hear someone coming, which is terrifying to me.
Is it someone I know?
Is it a monster?
Is it an employee to tell me to leave?
Only by waiting, will we know.
I'm scared.
Hello?
the good news is i can protect myself if it comes to that!
*saxophone playing*
It's a saxophone monster. *sounds amused*
Unknown Voice: "What are you doing in the dungeon?"
What are you doing in the dungeon, saxophone monster?
Unknown Voice: Practising the saxo-
*loud saxophone squeak*
This isn't great.
On our way to Austin and,
it's raining a lot
We gotta do a lot of this
To move this
That was a unideal driving day, luckily it was pretty short.
I feel like it is very easy to make people in music look cool.
And it is also like financially advantageous to do it.
Building up an image like a brand around an artist is vital to their success
and it's getting to be like how everybody presents themselves on the internet, too
We get to show everyone our best moments and
cut out all of the unpleasantness
all of the dirt
And more than ever, we have ways of getting scored on our performance
we get instagram likes and snapchat views and pins of your special cake on pintrest
I worry about that
Because just like how in school
we start to focus on the things that are easily quantifiable.
Maybe were gonna start to do the same thing in life.
I think we've always done it with dollars,
but now we have all these other metrics.
I think that might encourage us to forget about the things that maybe aren't as quantifiable,
but are, in the end, much more valuable.
Like having great poeple in your life,
helping take care of those people
doing things that you're proud of
regardless of the opinions of the masses
strengthening your communities
and being a part of something bigger than yourself.
That's just a thing that I've been thinking a lot about
as we drive through the country
which has been wonderful.
Thank you so much to everybody who's come out to the shows
And John, I'll see you on tuesday.
I AM A GOLDEN GOD!